alles was unkontrolliert die Bewegung
nicht nur eine sondern mehrmals
teilweise
und ich hasse aber wie mental nicht
akzeptieren jede Zeit die Frau leidet
dadurch Krankheit Endometriose bei der
chronischen Krankheit was
Gebärmutterschleimhaut
außerhalb von der gebärmutterhülle die
entzündete Endometriose Härte
verursachen unglaubliche Schmerzen
bestimmt eigentlich teilweise
informiert was das bedeutet und da
festgestellt dass sehr viel Frauen von
der Krankheit betroffen sind aber nie
mehr eigentlich genau weiß was das
bedeutet und dass sie leider auch sehr
oft nicht ernstgenommen wird und darum
werde ich mit Betroffenen reden und wird
ausdrücken nun kurzer Disclaimer ich
habe jetzt von Frauen
der Großteil auf der Welt sind aber
Frauen und darum benenne ich das auch so
hallo ich treffe Jessica den Schulen
gemacht im Jahr 2019 hat sie plötzlich
so krasse Bauchschmerzen bekommen dass
sie notfallmässig im Spital gelandet ist
sie ist vor Station zur Station
geschoben
wenn man dankt hat der entzündet die
Blinddarm ist schuld hat man da entfernt
aber Schmerzen sind Blubber buchkrampf
wie wenn
nicht nur eine sondern mehrmals
teilweise
Spezialist hätte Jessica
hormonbewirkt nämlich dass die
vorhandene endometrioseheitlichen
schrumpfen und so Schmerzen Abnahme
jessica hat aber stark ihn aber wirklich
von der Pille und such und dir für sie
nicht in frag und da geht's noch der
andere
ein Operation
jessica ist Anfang 2019 operiert wurde
aber inzwischen wieder zurück es ist
wirklich so Machtlosigkeit wo im Moment
wenn ich extrem zu Krampf
aber es ist nur ja knapp bis halbes Jahr
Haar seit der Operationen
ihre Beziehung und Sexualität ich glaube
das ist wirklich das
ich glaube jeder Schmerz beim Sport und
und
dann hat man Schmerzen Lust für Gott
wenn sie es wieder dazu kommt kann ich
dann wieder schmerzach nicht nachher
wieder von mir Schmerzen soll ich jetzt
im Vorhinein irgendetwas
[Musik]
weil ihr die vorgesetzt
als nächstes treffe ich Desiree als
Endometriose aber ihrem Arbeitsumfeld
wird mehr Verständnis zeigt für die
Krankheit
ich hoffe dass Physiotherapeutin in der
Praxis vor ihren älteren
2018 hat sich diagnosebüro und hat noch
einmal lange Lebensweg schon mehrere
Operationen hinter sich
[Musik]
unter anderem sind ihre in einer
Operation 15 cm vom Darm entfernt wurde
im Moment befindet sie sich in einer
guten Phase weil die letzte Operation
noch nicht langweilig
[Musik]
eigentlich immer gut wenn ich schaffe
vergiss es doch wieder Schmerzen
gebe dann muss ich aufpassen
aber so spielen
für mich einfach Techniker gefunden und
ich hocke halt eher mal ab zum Beispiel
ja ich weiß einfach dass so viele Stress
Level muss ich hier aufpassen und darum
mache jetzt immer eine Büro will ja das
geschafft haben übernehme und dann mache
ich immer mehr Büro und ich weiß doch
wie immer mehr jetzt sind deine fast
vier Jahre und jetzt die Diagnose haben
wie ich mit dem Körper muss umgehen wie
viel Operationen
und jetzt geht es mal wieder
das Problem oder das kann natürlich sie
aber ich hoffe es ehrlich gesagt
zu explizit über die Schmerzen redet
vielleicht weil sie gerade
stark sind ihre Mutter retten aber
Klartext
Privatbereich merkt man es viel stärker
dann kann sie es auch viel stärker
äußere denke ich also beim Schaffen ist
es schlimmste Problem da spielt sie
drüber hinweg also da merkt man nicht so
viel
Endometriose macht einfach mit seine
starke Schmerzen und ganz unsichere
Situation ein enormer psychische Druck
es ist Problem ist dass man nicht weiß
im wie stark die Schmerzen wirklich sind
und viele Hand ins Gefühl
Gefühl allem gut ihr merkt man es auch
nicht so an sie kann halb sterbe vor
Schmerzen und sie funktioniert immer
noch also sie hatten sehren hohe
Schmerzpegel und dadurch glaube ich dass
viele Leute im Spital dann in erster
Moment denke das kann nicht so schlimm
sein was für dich und drei oder ein
Vierer ist wäre vielleicht für jemand
anders immer noch am 16
Jessica weiß langsam nehmen wir wieder
darum besucht sie heute
[Musik]
ich wollte nicht jetzt schon operieren
grüß Gott du schaffst das ich merke
schnell die vier Frauen verbindet viel
vor allem auch dass sie lange nicht
Knoten sind vom Umfeld nicht und auch
nicht von der Arzt inne
aber dann hat es Umfeld du dir Zeit das
gehört zum Frau sie dazu
vielleicht bin ich einfach wirklich zu
empfinden
wieso nimmst du mich nicht ernst
verstorben
einfach nicht für mich die Schwachen
das hat mir eigentlich sehr gut da
nachdem
ja aber in dem Moment hat mir das sehr
gut da die Diagnose bekommen für das
nicht übrigens auch in Begriff das nennt
sich medical gaslightning die vier
Frauen ist es Selbsthilfegruppe hängt
noch fehlender schlechte Erfahrungen
aber allen Spezialist in gefunden wo sie
annimmt und sie auf ihrem Werk begleitet
es ist speziell gesehen
[Musik]
Diagnose fordert
Jessica und der
Selbsthilfegruppe macht jetzt
gefunden wie Jessica so alles wie eine
Schwamm auf
erschreckend finde ist wirklich dass sie
alle bestätigt und das sind und das ist
wirklich ein langer Weg ist bis es
erstmal zu einer Diagnose kommt
also es gibt zahlen und sie sagen dass
es durchschnittlich 9 Jahre lang gut bis
in Diagnose also Diagnose Endometriose
gestellt wird plus das betroffene im
Schnitt 5 Arzt in bzw 5 Spitaler
konsultiert bis zu der Diagnose Hund das
ist so lang
Desiree hat eineinhalb Jahre lang auf
ihre Diagnose müssen aber
eigentlich gar nicht die meisten
nachfragen
aber
also ich nicht so wieso
Frauenärztin
ja okay ich habe da vorher indem sie mir
Beschwerde kaufen buchen
oder also
Darmbeschwerden und so weiter und so
fort Müdigkeit an die wahnsinnig
ja und aber so jetzt auch wenn mich
Leute fragen was ich kann die meisten
kann ich das nicht
dass ihr das Umfeld nicht wüsstet was
endometriose ist kann ich verstehen ich
als vorminderer Diagnose selber auch
erzählt mir aber das hat Arzt in auch
bei mir hat es alles ab keine und was
weiß ich alles alles abgeklärt aber
Intoleranz und so und das ist ein
zufallsätze
und damit sie eine Ultraschall machen
war genau Ultraschall und das ist
festgestellt dass man gar nicht danach
gesucht
das hat schon ganze Ordner gefüllt mit
all ihren medizinischen Befund
ich habe das Gefühl es ist so
unspektakulär
e
reagiere
und weiß die Schmerzen wo du kannst aber
wie ist dies halt du hast mich einfach
immer die starken
ja und ich für mich ist halt nicht
spezielles für mich ist es
so also für mich ist total unspektakulär
ich finde so
ja interessiert das überhaupt für ganz
glücklich sein oder so aber ja ja
es schränkt dich ja schon im Leben
joggen und zeigt mit Spuren wo die
Operationen hinter lohend die vielen
Arbeit erinnere sehr schlimm mit 17
[Musik]
jetzt gerade am Zucker und ich mache das
gewisses
ich muss sagen ich finde es recht
beeindruckend wie sie über die Krankheit
wo sie hat wo sie jahrelang
drunter gelitten hat rett sie schmecken
aber man merkt schon immer wieder wenn
man sie dann wieder
Operationen kann so da merkt sie dass es
eigentlich schon nicht so normal ist
jetzt einfach schon sehr an die
Krankheit
was mich jetzt nur wundern nimmt ist
wie es den identifiziert ist was die
Krankheit für bezieht für den
einflusskeit und mit Partner und das
nimmt mich schon eine Wunder weil ich
glaube es hat schon Rechte Einfluss auf
Sexualität und auf die Kinderwunsch wo
mir nämlich gesagt wurden
und
falls Sie danach hin werden müssten
Hormontherapie machen
und ja es ist nicht so einfach wenn man
das mit 19 bekommt
es geht ja auch aber das Ding dass man
sagt wenn man in der metriose hätte ich
es schwieriger schwanger zu werden
über das Thema Kinderwunsch gemacht also
ich glaube nie wie du oder mein Gerät
und dann du hast ja gesagt
und du sollst einfach ganz Grippe
also wenn es deine Sowjet ist also jetzt
aktuell ist ja noch nicht aber und was
wird sich dann wird sich dem veränder
andere wenn du willst schwanger werden
ist ich weiß dass das keine runden
sicher wieder also das weiß mir
eigentlich aber so also es kann sich
nicht weg mit der Schwangerschaft also
Indianer bin dass es nachher wegkommt
aber ich glaube das ist leider nicht der
Fall will er die Gebärmutter schlimm Hut
oder das ähnliche Gewicht wieder Hund
das ist doch das Problem und da kannst
du dir da vorstellen
auf jeden Fall also das ist eigentlich
immer mein Plan sobald man Kinderwunsch
abgeschlossen hat
wo schwierig sie sind
von uns zwei Tage
drüber Psychologin
und ich nehme schon seit Jahren die
Depressiva und das hat wenigstens
stabilisiert
aber das geht halt immer wieder Phase ja
das ist halt weg viel Schmerzen haben
vor Demenz oder werden zu mit ihrem
Eisprung zum Beispiel wenn ich ihr
Schmerzen Handeln ich habe ihn Geduld
vor dass ihr gering und speerin
ich bewundere sie mir mega wie du selber
interessant und ich denke so hey krass
Operationen
liebenswerk also wie du mit dem Umgang
mehr
Probleme aber ich finde ich bin nicht
krank ich stelle mir einfach fragen
wieso Forschung
mit verschiedene Endometriose
Spezialistinnen
und wofür Sorge dass sie der Forschung
in der Forschung
Ursache zusammen zum Beispiel auch dass
man mit der hormonabhängigen Krankheit
weniger geldkur machen als zum Beispiel
mit der Krebsforschung und der dritte
Punkt wo er seit ist dass man einfach
immer noch nicht weiß woher und warum
geht es Endometriose und basic research
und das auch hinterher hinke wenn man
einfach kein Zelle hat wo man kann
untersuchen ich persönlich würde mir
wünschen dass nur Filme gerade
Hausärztinnen und Hausarzt Bescheid
wissen über die Krankheit und so ist
Krankheitsbild auf viel schneller können
Kommentare
und wenn du noch mehr vor